[Musique]
maître gims avait déclaré c'est bon
c'est bon il avait déclaré non en direct
des médias vouloir être juré de the
voice maître gims et bien justement
après avoir vu ça est-ce que vous pensez
que maître gims faire un bon jeu allez
dites la vérité bonne idée ou mauvaise
idée
et là vous leur dites pas ce que vous
lui donnez votre avis la dernière fois
ouais je veux votre avis maintenant
bonne idée mathieu absolument et là j'ai
vraiment je sais par totalement l'ami de
n'est pas neutre que du bon non jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors rien n'a pour devrait franchement
je trouve que c'est c'est actuellement
pour être très honnête le chanteur le
plus populaire
maintenant on est rarement populaire
sans talent je ne connais pas de
chanteurs qui s'opère sans talent il a
une voix exceptionnelle chez ruquier
quand il a chanté a cappella ya très peu
de chanteurs qui acceptent de chanter
sur un plateau comme ça ils chantent et
extrêmement bien il change juste il ne
fait que dès que des recherches une
cache nana mais voilà que des succès
populaires et je trouve qu'il aurait
vraiment totalement totalement sa place
d'autant qu'il faut vraiment retenu le
jury maintenant c'est pour ça que j'ai
tout fait mais je vous le dis je suis
persuadé et je dis pas ça parce que il
s'est glissé que m
voilà je pense qu'ils prendraient 2,3
points encore parce que maître gims ce
serait un énorme événement norris pour
moi je lis ça serait encore ses salles à
leila il passe encore un cap
benjamin castaldi alors je te naître
avant de le voir commenter les chanteurs
ont sévi en loge
moi je trouve ce n'est pas une bonne
idée mais après ce qu'il a dit oui c'est
une excellente idée parce qu'il parle
bien la musique qui m'a bien des
artistes et on sent qu'il aime vraiment
les gens et la musique donc et surtout
vous avez qui voit la frappe de payet
[ __ ] sur la gueule
jean marie continue et les chiffres il
en va rigoler avec maître gims
m'apprendre à moi rigoler parce que
c'est pas parce que je rigole avec m in
school souhaite je suis pas énervé je
voulais d'ailleurs y'a pas de houle à la
moyenne ont brûlé un truc il avait
traîné rien un truc de ouf frère mais
vraiment je suis face à 60 ans est un
thriller quelque chose mais je vais de
révéler et là là là bas lala générique
générés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
dans un instant je vous réveillerez
lodro dossier ça va nous prendre
beaucoup de temps mais si on va revenir
sur tout ce qui s'est passé à la télé
mais ça va nous prendre beaucoup de
temps et je vous révèlerai ou également
si je suis allé avec agathon concert de
kent jean bart
d'accord ce sera également un instant
j'espère que ça fera mal un vrai concert
de kent jugez vous l'aimez bien quelques
mois il a repris bella et c est la bonne
et on ne verra gens ne boudait banal je
la hais les magasins au venezuela alors
maître guy n'a jamais saint denis at on
jamais fismic et parfums ici m'ont fait
signer pour que je me barre booba
dérivés die alors effectivement moi
comme patiemment pourrait tout à fait
honnête avant en loge moi je pensais que
ce n'était pas une bonne idée pour non
pas parce que vous n'étiez pas un bon
chanteur ou autres mais parce que
j'avais peur que ça fasse un doublon
avec matt pokora mon côté on a deux
jurys de membres du jury qui sont plutôt
pour un public jeune mais en
l'occurrence visible bien qu élémentaire
voilà complètement sur des terrains qui
ne sont pas les mêmes et alors le seul
souci qui va se poser du coup c'est
qu'il faudra enlever quelqu'un est là et
la personne - alors avant de dire qu'il
vous enlevez en même temps vous enlevez
clip on voit que m games tient 6 mois ou
en benjamins 1 zazie oui merci
c'est ce que j'avais dit aux gens d'ici
c'est alors bon mathieu moi j'aimerais
me cas aujourd'hui
alors ouais vous alors valérie bénaïm
moisi parce que je pense que l'enfant
lac est excellente idée donc il a la
voix il a le talent pour juger les
sujets des artistes et en plus sur the
voice la version américaine qui a
commencé en 2011 ya maintenant onze
saisons il ya toujours un turnover au
niveau des jurys en a deux qui sont
immuables qui sont adam levin et blake
shelton
dans mon cas il faudrait que les deux
autres tournent donc matt pokora et
zazie moi je les enlève vrai je mettrais
m 2 pour la saison prochaine et une
autre femme l'accord va très bien m'a
fait de balayer les allées sur tf1 qui
coûta salute et décroche sa mère
j'enlève les 2h mais maxime guény de
médias plus bonne idée excellente idée
il a passé d'excellentes d'elle et je
veux faire un secret d'histoire dit vite
fait alors ne sais quelle histoire il
est simple parce que vous vous apporter
quelque chose de très urbain si vous
pouviez entre n'est en tout cas
appartenir à cette seule famille the
voice qui se veulent à partir tout
simplement le coach belge à florent
pagny font les talents j'ai l'impression
qu'il se tourne progressivement vers les
nouveaux arrivés oui en panne et je le
dis papa ni maman et le bébé d'un côté
bamakois je suis d'accord avec vous
panini
elle renouvelle phocéen aussi le combat
n'est ni papa alors vous vous dites
mauvaises idées alors vous déjà en
maître gims tu le prends bien parce
qu'il ne vous aime pas non non c'est ce
que je déteste
mauvaise idée on a demandé l'avis des
piétons aussi la bd plutôt dit non pas
une mauvaise idée est revenu dans le
jury contrairement aux petits camarades
je ne change pas d'avis entre la loge
est maintenant et en danse
c'est vrai j'ai dit à la dernière
émission parce qu'il y en a qui tourne
un peu rapidement leurs vestes changé je
pense que c'est une mauvaise idée parce
qu'effectivement je pense que c'est un
peu sur le même créneau de chanteur très
populaire puisque évidemment vous avez
une voix vous êtes très populaire là
dessus j'ai aucun problème mais je pense
que ça serait sur le même créneau et
quitte à avoir quelqu'un quelqu'un
d'urbain je mettrais quelque chose sur
du rap un peu plus dur parce que je
pense que ça manque effectivement sur se
voit exploit c'est ce que la jeune star
pardon je l'espère n'ont pas joué ce
terme est par exemple cela sur ce vol
non non non moi j'ai eu moi je crois
dans le serait à moins d'être très
honnêtement j'étais au stade sur the
voice jeudi la droite y est toujours
eric on perd 500 milles au quart d'heure
sur des colis non mais et pour va gagner
des dentistes mais on va perdre plateau
la vérité
et puis en plus en plus je sais qu'ils
mangent des pizzas là bas c'est qu'il
n'aime pas ça vous voulez moi depuis le
début je dis que c'est une super bonne
idée je pense qu'il n'a rien à voir avec
matt pokora
les fans de maitre gims se sont pas les
mêmes que ceux de maths et en plus de ça
je pense que maître gims je les trouve
un petit peu lisse mois les jury de the
voice et je pense qu'il pourra apporter
un côté un petit peu justement un peu
plus rentre dedans et qui n'a pas peur
de dire les choses et pour ça moi je
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
j'aimerais bien qu'il est sans merci bon
dans le coeur bat non mais j'étais
d'accord avec valérie je suis toujours
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un doublon m.pokora je trouve que
c'était super des maître gims et ça
reste une super idée mais par contre
s'il vient se pensent qu'il ferait en
des mêmes poca qui est vachement bien
donc ça problème annonce il y avait là
moi je pense à la première fois j'avais
dit ça m'est un peu égal mais je le
verrais bien ou à la place de zazie ou
en 5e jurait j'ai pas changer la vie
maintenant je trouve c'est une super
idée est toujours à la place de zazie et
surtout pas enlever florent pagny parce
que vous devriez vous faire sourire mais
en salle
oui c'est ça la c'est complémentaire
aussi vu jean michel il a tout il a le
talent qu'il a il est très populaire
donc moi je verrais très bien moi dans
le jury de the voice en plus moi je
traîne pas mal mes oreilles le week-end
savez dans les bars
[Rires]
et généralement généralement quand vous
traitez quelque part ses potes vos
oreilles qu'on entend parler est ce que
le disent le plus les gens c'est qu'ils
ont marre des couilles molles à hasuobs
et et les coups très durs
donc moi je suis pour à plat excusez moi
vous pouvez pas faire une classe normale
à son cou ils sont installés sur les
côtés
changé c'est vrai que nous avons un
franc parler mine de rien le truc c'est
vrai à wissant c'est vrai si six
batteries sur nrj music awards sur les
habitants de la musique vous y allez
vous y allez ouais c'est moi je trouve
que j'évite de faire trop plein tous
agissent trop de conneries c'est vrai
maître gims en tout cas on va voir tout
de suite ce qu'on pense les twittos
c'est ce qu'il trouve que c'est une
bonne idée ou pas est ce qu est ce que t
es ce que tf1 ou la production shine
besoin vous ont pas besoin de parler ou
pas du tout si vous en approcher non dit
la vérité du tout hanouna les yeux dans
les nets gains concrets gérer ainsi dire
rien de la vie vous on est bon nous on a
peu parlé m'ont demandé si je regardais
l'émission et que j'adorerais français
voudraient j'avance je regarde si j'ai
un conseil à leur donner et vraiment je
pense que ce serait énorme d'avoir
maître gims ans membre du jury dans sur
la prochaine saison 2 de the voice
maitre gims eurent tout cas on te kiffe
grave on va regarder tout de suite le
remercier loin bien sûr madame c'est
normal